uh ladies and gentlemen thank you very
much for
inviting me to present on precision
medicine the triple
helix approach you're seeing here the
university of glasgow the beautiful
um old university that i work
for what we have built
um in our very modern the biggest acute
hospital
in the united kingdom the queen
elizabeth university hospital
is the triple helix approach
where the university the academia leads
working very very closely with national
health service and interest
industry to introduce the innovation
that is useful for patients that
directly addresses the needs
of the health system and that triangle
with our new hospital at the background
shows that triple helix approach that
is the philosophy behind our
health innovation activities where we
collaborated
actively with thermo fisher scientific
of course in order to innovate you need
excellence
and that slide illustrates how
biomedicine in glasgow
has reached true excellence and this is
just one example
five firsts uk white in the complete
university
guide 2021 and you see here that our
medicine
nursing dentistry veterinary medicine
and sports science
are all first in the uk and we're very
proud of it
on the basis of this excellence we can
proceed to do new things to innovate
we also very lucky to have partners
willing
and innovative partners
in our nhs greater glasgow and clyde
hills board
and you see here that colleagues in the
nhs
provide cover for very large part of
scottish population
and have very high quality laboratories
that allow us to together do
very new work particularly in the area
of
pharmacogenetics and pharmacogenomics
and this is our precision medicine
innovation center
where we have collaborated with number
of companies
but therma fisher was our first and
strongest supporter
in this endeavor the
innovation center has been working
since 2014 and you see six
exemplar projects that addressed
precision medicine in number of cancers
and inflammatory disorders
with very large amount of success
in this endeavors and the work on
ovarian cancer
pancreatic cancer rheumatoid arthritis
and multiple sclerosis
have really made big difference
for the health delivery and this is
pan scottish collaboration and also
national and international uk wide and
beyond collaboration
in these projects
we have built and created clinical
innovation zone
in our clinical academic center
this covers two separate
buildings and brings industry big and
small
to work together with clinicians and
scientists
to bring innovation to the health
delivery
using this triple helix approach
that i described before
and here you see the
recently published science in innovation
audit that we published with department
of business energy
and industrial strategy in london where
we have identified number of
opportunities
both international and scottish in
scotland and
uk opportunities that precision medicine
can bring
scotland wide so first of all
we know that precision medicine is a
growing
has a growing market value moving from
2016 to 2025 by several
orders of magnitude and moreover
in scotland alone precision medicine if
applied
according to the principles that we
discuss in this document
it could save the national health
service approximately
1.5 billion pounds over the five years
and this has been
a work performed by health economists
who work very closely with us
and here you see one example of already
delivered opportunity which is the
eye care study industrial center for
artificial intelligence research in
digital diagnostics
which is led by professor david harrison
and you see here
has a number of academic nhs and
industrial partners as shown here
on the map of the uh
of scotland and uk and you you see
very clearly here that
this is a work that
will change the way the
digital pathology and digital theology
is practiced in scotland
and beyond scotland the internationally
and the real game-changing opportunity
that has come
from our science in innovation audit is
described here this is the living
laboratory it is a funded now
opportunity
recently funded opportunity um
funded by ukri one of the
biggest grants we have ever had a
chance to be awarded and you see here
that it will operate
in the queen elizabeth university
hospital and other
related centers and
it will serve the population with
multiple
deprivation and with
polypharmacy which i'll explain in a
minute
and multimorbidity so
patients population where there is a lot
of chronic disease
chronic disease that requires multiple
drugs
which causes problems in itself
so here is a quick
description what the living laboratory
will bring
to medicine to scottish medicine and to
international medicine
and the idea is that we will implement
the pharmacogenomics based medication
management
as one of our early and important use
cases
and this will accelerate
ability to serve the nhs in scotland
ability to serve patients whilst also
giving us so much needed economic growth
creating new jobs for this deprived
area of scotland and uk
and you see here number of use cases
that are part of this big program of the
living laboratory
i mentioned pharmacogenomics based
medication management this is the key
project and i'll say a few words about
it in a minute
we will also do scottish transcript
transcriptome archive resource in short
star
we will advance imaging for precision
medicine
using ai and other modifications
and innovations we will have digital
health validation laboratory
and we will build a new building
the health innovation hub to extend
and increase all these activities
why is it important to do
pharmacogenomics
and to make sure that we control
polypharmacy polypharmacy means many
medications defined as
two or more medications and it
is particularly used in patients with
multi-morbidity who have multiple
conditions frequently patients
of age 65 and above
and this is the reason for
adverse reactions unplanned admissions
and huge additional
both suffering for patients and
increased cost
to health services all over the world
um so we
believe that the program that we
planning um on
the pharmacogenomics will be
enormously important to prevent adverse
reactions but also
to reduce the unnecessary hospital
admissions
and other adverse effects for patients
you see here that for patients over 65
years of age many many are
on multiple medications and 50 percent
of the adverse reactions that require
hospital admissions
are preventable with the methods we are
currently implementing
and to summarize this very important use
case
we have already performed some
preliminary
activity some preliminary in
silico calculations and modeling
and it showed that in this one
area of scotland um we have
the um we we have
a lot of patients who are on
polypharmacy
you see here that interestingly we
have very large cohort of patients on
three plus medications 165
000 namely that average number of
medications is much more than we thought
eight that most prevalent under
condition is high blood pressure
and most costly as we would expect
diabetes
by introducing um
pharmacogenomic way of medication
management
we could prevent
large number of adverse reactions we can
reduce the annual health
care spend very significantly with
calculated
savings of more than 85 million
pounds over three years for our system
for relatively small population one can
think that
extending this to entire country
or beyond would be a real
real real gain for the health systems
and for the population at large
so very quickly also
the additional resources that we will
produce is the scottish transcriptomes
archive resource with 30 000
mrna from clinical samples from
clinical tissues from human tissue that
would be
openly available to number of
clinical and drug discovery activities
throughout
our health system the
next use case is our digital health
validation laboratory
where we are inviting companies big and
small
to join with us to be able
to validate various innovations
such as ai
for example applied to imaging or
digital pathology and this would be done
in the middle of clinical campus with
ability to interact with clinicians and
scientists
and this is what the companies that work
with us
have asked us as the major
need that the companies have to embed
the activities in a real
clinical scenarios and last but not
least
our new health innovation hub that will
bring it all together
in a new purpose-built purpose-designed
building where we work with world-famous
developer with a special interest
in these type of clinical
science-based activities that
join academia health delivery and
industry
so a true triple helix activities
i just want to switch for last two
slides to something that is already
happening
in the same place in the same
living laboratory this is of course
testing for covet working
with colleagues from thermo fisher we
have developed
at the end of march the covet
testing laboratory and national facility
for scotland
that uses the same space and the same
living
laboratory philosophy that is triple
helix
of academia nhs in industry this
laboratory
has been one of um
great helpers to our health service
and it has currently exceeded
uh one and a half million of tests from
zero start as shown on this slide
and i just would like to acknowledge
enormous help
of our students our staff our scientists
our technicians who came and volunteered
we had more than 800 volunteers when we
started in march and we also would like
to thank colleagues from thermo fisher
who have who have been with us
throughout this journey
building completely new uh
industrial scale laboratory with
thousands of samples